by Willem you have a lot of tips in here
and but chapter one you go in depth how
to suck less a makeup right so we have a
volunteer Lauren help me an idiot
volunteers w9 here we want to just and
you said you have three good ones I have
some three fun quick drag one that's not
a very trendy on trend on point as you
say it is an education on thing is that
drag queens are so much better than the
average person help me
one of my favorite things to do is take
a sheet of star stickers and then I just
go okay well I do it more carefully
usually I peel it off like that I feel
off a chunk of it and then you have like
a little stencil so like here yeah right
there
hold on oh yeah you hold that spell hell
yeah and then you just take like some
pretty colors these are all my OCC
palette and go like a little pain well
part ball will go boom and we do we do
not a slush right there no much voila
not cool because you can't there's no
mirror all right that's good
I feel prettier great yeah they're
really great I think we just need to
punch them up a little bit the best way
to make a beauty mark
Ortega's it and make it into a beauty
mark is you take the pencil and go put
it down and then twirl twirl one here
you try it
Oh nervous don't screw this up like say
my bar or a different spot anywhere you
want oh great I'm gonna keep not there
Oh wherever you want I want to give her
a little Cindy Crawford that's great let
me say what we didn't get anything good
well yeah you suck some of it to light
on the touch that one you do know if
that's hurt oh that's perfect you know
what I'm done
- straight that's how it is
I'm going to get your arm for this
because I don't need to race anymore I
want to show you what it looks like with
you know just put it on dry like that
okay now I'm going to take a little bit
of water okay so I just wet the brush a
little bit and now I'm going to dip it
in powder and let's get different you
see how it intensifies it just a little
bit of water I usually use spit which is
why if the brush was Krusty's that's why
that's that it doesn't feel savvy at all
but not my dredge to fit but there's my
good tricks like sparkles using water
intensify makeup and then just using
stencils and having fun with it it's
like my childhood is met my womanhood
and I'm sexy and fun but left where
there's a will there's a way
oh god that was me
thanks for watching ET on youtube but
where's my way before you go there's
plenty more where that came from
all you got to do is hit the subscribe
button